VISHAY NIHALANI: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming out today.
My name is Vishay Nihalani, and
I'm joined by Flo Thng.
Flo and I are both product
managers who work
at Google on AdMob.
So just by show of hands, how
many of you here are familiar
with AdMob?
And how many of you are
app developers?
Excellent.
And how many of you app
developers have actually
included AdMob in one of your
applications, either to
monetize, or used AdMob
to promote?
FLO THNG: Yeah!
VISHAY NIHALANI: Well, it's
great to see that so many of
you are active and
have used AdMob.
You guys are at the center of a
thriving mobile app ecosystem.
And we're really proud
to be part of that.
Every day we see that users are
downloading more and more
applications, and spending
more time in those
applications as well.
So at AdMob, our goal is to help
be a partner for you, and
help you promote and monetize
your application successfully.
The pace of growth
is absolutely
staggering with apps.
And no doubt, that growth
creates some interesting
challenges.
At AdMob we see three
major challenges.
These are around discovery,
monetization, and the user
experience.
There are now over 1.6 million
applications across the Google
Play and iOS app stores
combined.
That's great choice for users,
but what does that mean for
you as an app developer?
As an app developer, that
means that you have to
constantly jockey for place in
the marketplace rankings in
order to get your app in
front of your users.
So it's important to be
incredibly deliberate about
how you promote your
app to your users.
On the monetization side, as
your user base grows, you
expect your revenue
to grow with it.
And doing that might
involve working
with multiple ad networks.
But working with multiple
networks can be challenging,
both technically and
operationally.
And on the user experience side,
it's important to be
tactful about how you show
adds to your users.
A bad experience can ruin
the user's experience.
It can put off your existing
users from using your app, and
it can turn away new users
if they see bad
reviews in the app store.
And as a developer, you're
including content from third
party sources.
So you want to make sure that
the content that shows up in
your application enhances
your brand rather
than tarnishes it.
You want to make sure that the
ads that show up are relevant,
engaging, and appropriate
for your users.
[BREAK IN AUDIO]
VISHAY NIHALANI: Just
this year--
[BREAK IN AUDIO]
VISHAY NIHALANI: This is just
the first step to opening the
floodgates of monetization.
And we hope to see tremendous
growth in this area.
And of course, we want to help
preserve the user experience.
We have a team at AdMob that's
working on building innovative
new ad formats that help
preserve the user's experience
within your application.
We're building ad formats that
inherently verify that the
user is actually interested in
the ad content before taking
them out of your app and
onto the landing page.
So with an eye toward solving
some of these challenges, I am
really excited to announce the
launch of a brand new AdMob.
This new AdMob is laser
focused on apps.
At the same time, we've brought
the power of AdSense
and AdWords to mobile apps.
We've leveraged more than a
decade of innovation and
experience to bring you the
scale and reliability that
Google offers across all
of its ads products.
Our goal is to make it
incredibly simple for you to
promote and monetize
your applications.
The idea is to make it very
simple for you to promote and
monetize so that you, as a lone
app developer with an
idea, can go to becoming a team
of app developers working
on building a sustainable
business like Chris in this
video we're about to show.
We hope that this will be a
familiar aspiration for many
of you in the audience.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Inspiration can come from some
pretty unlikely places.
But once it hits, there's
a lot of work to do.
Designing an app takes months
of programming, problem
solving, and testing.
But finally you have something
you're happy with.
And now, with AdMob, you can
earn a return on all your work
by showing relevant
ads in your app.
Then, with AdMob's promotion
tools, watch your app take off
in a bigger way than
you imagined.
From success at home to
downloads online, AdMob
connects your app
with millions of
advertisers and users.
So now that you're earning
money, you'll have more time
to build your business,
and get inspired for
your next great app.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
VISHAY NIHALANI: And with that,
I'd like to introduce
Flo, who's going to talk about
some of the features that
we've built into the new AdMob
to improve app promotion.
FLO THNG: All right.
Thanks, Vishay.
Hi, everyone.
You saw some flashes of the new
interface in the video.
Now let's dive into the demo so
we can share with you some
of the exciting features in the
new AdMob to help you get
more users and make more
money from your apps.
We redesigned the UI into
three core sections.
Home, Monetize, and Promote.
Home tab is basically
a dashboard.
We pulled together all your
stats in one place to help you
get an overview on how your app
business is performing.
On the top here, you can see a
summary on how much money I've
made from my apps today.
And how many downloads
that AdMob has
driven to all my apps.
When you scroll down, we can see
more granular stats, like
RPM, fill rate, conversion.
It's nice to see that we're
getting more and more
conversion here.
And the best part, my favorite,
is that we've
organized all of this by app, so
you can quickly review and
figure out the action needed.
For example, Line Up is getting
quite a number of users.
Maybe it's time for us to
start monetizing it.
Or Flooded here, which is
actually earning me quite a
bit of money.
So I could consider actually
promoting it even more.
Which brings us to
the Promote tab.
Promote tab is the hub for
advertising with AdMob.
One of the advantages
of advertising with
AdMob is our scale.
Because we work with app
developers worldwide, like
yourself, we have billions of
users in the AdMob network.
And we've designed it so that
you can create a campaign to
reach all of those users with
just a few simple steps.
So I'm going to create
a new campaign today.
And the first step is to
just pick a campaign
that I want to promote.
I see a lot of you enjoying your
Chrome Pixel, so I will,
in honor of that, promote
a Chrome app.
All you have to do is just type
it in, and you see that
we pull automatically from the
two major app stores the most
likely app that I
was looking for.
Which in this case
is Chrome Beta.
So I will just select it.
No need to put any package ID.
And you can do image
ad or text ad.
I didn't have time to create an
image ad, so I'm going to
go with text ad today.
Good thing is AdMob is going to
help me make this text ad
more engaging and informative.
So all I have to do is create
a campaign name, an ad name,
put a bit for a CPC.
So I will put in $0.08.
We pull in the destination
URL directly.
Save you some steps.
And the best part here is we can
preview what it looks like
in different formats.
In tablet, in phone.
And we've made this a lot more
informative and engaging for
the users, because you can see
now, there is that Chrome
logo, the review information,
the rating information.
The goal is to make this app
informative so that users will
click on it and then download.
The next step is figuring out
who do I want to target with
this promotion.
So, because this is I/O
specific, I might want to
target just people
in San Francisco.
And each of these targeting
settings
is very easily editable.
AdMob also, because we're
connected to Google Play, will
know automatically that Chrome
Beta requires Android 4.0 and
up in order to run properly.
The OS setting is
correctly set.
This is only going to get
shown to users who are
eligible to download your app.
Now I just need to set a daily
budget, name this.
And I've just create the
Chrome app promotion.
Now what I want to know is how
effective is this campaign?
How many users is it going
generate for me?
And how much are these
users going to be?
The good thing is we've
integrated conversion tracking
into the campaign
creation flow.
So if you are promoting an app,
all you have to do is hit
Confirm and Finish here,
and you're all
done for Android app.
Or if you happen to have
analytics data, and you know
what is the value for conversion
for your app, you
can put in this optional
value here.
I'm going to put $2.
And just with that, AdMob will
automatically start tracking
the users who have clicked on
your app and then download it.
For iOS, it is a little
bit more involved.
You will have to include a short
code snippet in your
app, which you can access from
the App Conversion tab.
If you click on Edit, this
nice little pencil here,
you'll be able to get
that snippet here.
And we've made it easy, because
you can just email it
to yourself.
Which I'm going to skip now.
If you're an app developer,
and I'm sure many of you
actually have multiple apps,
not just one, you can jump
start your new app by
cross-promoting it to your
existing user base.
And AdMob allows you to do that
easily with house apps.
So when you create a new
campaign, you can also select
to create a house app.
For example, if I want to
promote the Chrome app here to
LabPixies users, I'm going to
just do the same thing.
All of these is the
same as before.
The one new step is we now
display all of the add units
that you have created
for your app.
So I'm going to select Color
Drips and Flooded, which means
that this Chrome promotion
is going to show
in these two games.
I save it.
And because this is house app,
and we're promoting this to
your own inventory, you don't
need to set a budget.
We can actually do
this for free.
Next is you just allocate
your inventory.
So don't forget to do
this so that your
campaign will start serving.
Once everything is set up--
I've set up house app campaign,
regular campaign--
you can monitor the performances
of all of these
campaigns through our reporting
setting, which is in
these All Apps table.
So I can easily see which one of
my apps is converting well,
how much it is costing me to
convert, and what is the cost
per conversion.
So this is really cool, because
I've set up conversion
tracking for all of this app,
I'll be able to know how much
it's costing me to
get somebody to
download a Chrome browser.
The next step is
to optimize it.
So if you click on any one of
these apps, you'll be able to
see that I've set up
multiple campaigns.
Some of them are doing better
than the others.
And I've set up multiple ads,
and some are converting better
than the others.
So I might want to actually
optimize.
And we allow inline editing, so
I can just go in here and
say, maybe I need to
actually bid higher
and get better users.
Or I can go to Campaign tab and
says, the second campaign
is doing really well.
I want to actually increase
the budget.
This is all, however, quite
manual you have to actually go
in there, figure out which
one is doing well.
Maybe create your own model.
So today we're really excited
to announce a new feature in
AdMob, which is called
Conversion Optimizers.
Conversion Optimizers will allow
you to set the bid based
on a target cost per
acquisition.
Basically, you just tell AdMob
how much you're willing to pay
for users, and let us do
the heavy lifting.
We are going to look at your
conversion history.
So we look at your campaign,
which one is performing well.
And we look at a bunch
of other signals.
And we have very complex
model in the back end.
All of these so that we can
predict when an impression
comes out whether it's going to
be very valuable for you.
So we're going to bid
higher for it.
And then for the less valuable
click, we're going to bid
lower for it.
In order to do this,
you just have to
click Edit on the campaigns.
Oh, sorry.
OK.
We're having some--
so when you click on the
campaign, these are--
we're having some
network problem.
But you should be able to
actually switch bidding from
bidding on CPC to bidding on--
I'm going to show it
to a different way.
Sorry.
This is what happens when
we run a live demo.
Quite exciting.
So you can see here, you will be
able to switch your bidding
option from focusing on clicks
to focusing on conversion.
You can put in a target cost
per acquisition here.
I'm putting in $1.08.
That's how much I'm willing to
pay to get a user on Chrome,
because my RPU is really,
really high.
I can put in a lower number and
actually reduce my cost
per acquisition.
Just keep in mind, that means
the number of downloads that
I'm going to get is
going to be lower.
If I had put in a larger number,
like $2, I will get a
lot more download.
What we recommend is actually
put in a conversion cost close
to what you have right now.
So Conversion Optimizer, it's
important to keep in mind,
it's not the same as a
guaranteed cost per install.
The result is going to vary.
However, most people who have
implemented it have seen
really great results.
So our early testers have
seen reduction in
conversion costs by 20%.
We work with Gree, one of the
game developers in Japan.
They implemented conversion
optimizers across multiple of
their campaign, and they were
able to reduce their cost of
user acquisition by 50%.
Basically the same budget, they
get twice as many users.
Who doesn't love that?
So with this, hopefully, all of
you now can create your own
app promotion campaign.
We strongly suggest when you
do that, set up conversion
tracking so you'll be able
to know how much it
costs to get a user.
And please try out Conversion
Optimizer so AdMob can help
you optimize your budget.
With that, I'll hand it back to
Vishay, who is going to go
through Monetization tab,
and help you make more
money with your app.
VISHAY NIHALANI: Thanks, Flo.
So now that you've promoted
your application, you've
gotten tons and tons
of downloads.
The next step is to consider
modernizing those users.
So I'll quickly walk you through
what it's like to set
up monetization in one
of your applications.
So let's say we want
to monetize the
same Chrome Beta app.
So first select the
application.
As you can see, one of the
changes from the legacy AdMob
to this new interface is that
your inventory is actually
organized by application.
This is great for you because
it adds organization.
But it's also great because
it allows us to run some
interesting quality models to
really optimize your apps,
rather than arbitrary
ad units.
So let's say we want to
set up an ad unit.
It's quite simple.
Let's say you have a banner
on the bottom screen.
You can create this ad unit, see
a nice preview of the ad
unit, save it.
And just like on the promote
side, you can easily email the
instructions on how to
integrate the ad
unit to your developer.
So once you've done that and
released your application,
you'll start to see revenue pour
into your application.
It's fairly simple.
Now, the thing to consider is
making sure that you're
showing the right ads
to the right users.
So with our new publisher
controls feature, we allow you
to very easily categorize all of
the ads that are showing up
in your application, and allow
or block them by category.
So as you can see in this
interface, we launched the
ability for you to sort your
ads into hundreds of
categories, so that you can
make sure that only
appropriate ads show
to your audience.
We also have the ability to
see how much revenue is
actually coming from each
category of ad, so that you
can make an intelligent decision
on the risks versus
rewards of blocking certain
categories.
Many of you also may have
a concern about showing
competitors' applications
advertisements in your app.
So with this new feature, we
allow you to actually block
ads by the landing page URL.
So for example, if you're Chrome
and you want to block--
let's use an arbitrary
example.
Let's say you want to block
a particular game.
You can grab the URL from the
iTunes or Google Play store,
drop it in here, and
click Block.
And we'll make sure that that
competitor's apps don't show
up in your application.
So now that you've set up your
publisher controls and your
filters, you may find your
inventory start to grow.
And in that case, you may want
to work with multiple ad
networks to monetize
your inventory.
So we've made it incredibly
simple to add multiple ad
networks to your ad source.
So assuming that you've dropped
the SDKs into your
application already, it's very
straightforward to add more ad
networks because each ad
unit, by default, is
configured for mediation.
So to do that, simply add
another ad network.
Let's say in this case we want
to add the AdMob eCPM Floor.
Click Save.
And essentially, the
way mediation--
[BREAK IN AUDIO]
VISHAY NIHALANI: --that
network doesn't
fill the add request.
We'll kick it down to the next
highest paying ad network, and
so on, in order to maximize your
revenue per impression.
So simply set up what you've
been getting paid
from each ad network.
And by default, we'll start
to optimize your revenue.
So we hope these features will
be incredibly useful for you
as you monetize and promote
your application.
Just to recap, we've kind of
launched five key improvements
in this new interface.
These are smarter app promotion
and conversion
optimizer, simplified
mediation, robust ad
filtering, intelligent
reporting, and some of you in
the audience may be really
excited to hear that for
developers who are outside of
the United States, we are
launching local currency
payments all over the world.
We hope that this will make it
easier for you guys to get
paid and to start spending
your money.
So with that, I'd like to show
you some of our really
exciting new app formats which
we believe are really
innovative and will really catch
your users' attention.
So the first--
I often play this game.
It's called Line Up.
And the basic concept is to
clear all these blocks away.
I often play this game while I'm
kind of waiting in line at
the cafes at Google.
And so in between levels--
let's say I'm
done with this level.
I start a new game.
I think we're having some
network connectivity issues.
There we go.
And so just like with TrueView
on the web, we've introduced
TrueView on the mobile apps.
So in this particular case, in
between the levels, it's a
natural time to show an ad.
We can actually present this
video ad to the user.
They can watch the ad, see if
they're interested in it.
If they are, they can keep
watching the video.
In this case, I've
seen this ad.
It's pretty cool.
It's the Chrome ad from Paris.
It's pretty sweet.
But I've already seen it before,
so I want to skip it,
and I want to get back
to playing this game.
So to do that, I just click the
Skip Ad button, and just
like that I'm back
in the game.
So we hope that ad formats like
this one will help to
preserve the user experience,
and also increase the
advertiser ROI, so that they're
only receiving clicks,
and they're only receiving
users who are actually
interested in the content
that they have on offer.
So with that, I'd like to show
you all the story of Toni
Fingerroos You might have heard
of him from the game
Hill Climb Racing.
In three months, working long
hours by himself, he built an
app that now has tens of
millions of downloads.
We believe our new platform
will help create many more
success stories just
like this one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I like cars I built myself.
That's one of my hobbies.
I own this old Toyota Supra,
which we put the engine and
all that stuff into.
I guess it's a little bit in me
that I want to do something
on my own, build things.
Even it's a game or a car.
My name is Toni Fingerroos.
I come from Oulu, Finland.
We have a start up there
called Fingersoft.
It creates mobile
games and apps.
After developing several years
for a PlayStation game that
was still unpublished, I just
wanted to see some results,
and get my work shown to people
around the world.
So I started working on Hill
Climb Racing alone.
I spent like three months
working on it,
about 16 hours a day.
The character itself, it's
actually drawn by my fiance.
Hill Climb Racing has had over
60 million downloads.
That's quite a lot.
That's really started
generating revenue.
About 40% comes from
advertisements, and AdMob is
our cornerstone.
With AdMob you have several
different ways to show
advertisements.
So we place them on the bottom
of the screen, and during game
play we hide all the
apps so it doesn't
interrupt the user at all.
We have users all around
the world.
So we have to feel
advertisements in global scale.
And I think AdMob is doing
a really good job.
I got enough money from AdMob so
I could develop Fingersoft
applications and games
full time.
If I show it like this--
see?
-Yeah, that's great.
-This is office we started.
Just a room from my place.
You can see me there.
This is the new office.
There's the work stations.
That's the pool table.
And then, of course, the Finnish
style sauna which we
can relax in and design new
products and ideas.
So have a few beers
and take it easy.
I think it's awesome when you
get to create something, and
you get it finished, and then
you receive customer feedback.
And if they like it,
it's really nice.
And people like it,
and we like it.
That's great.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK ENDS]
VISHAY NIHALANI: So I hope you
guys are all as excited to
access the new AdMob as
I am to share it.
We'll be rolling out this new
interface to new users.
And if you have an existing
account, be on the lookout for
an upgrade notification.
You can upgrade to the new
AdMob without making any
changes to your existing
application.
So you don't have
to go through an
extensive release process.
And with that, we'll turn it
over to Q&A. Go ahead.
I think there's a mic there.
AUDIENCE: While we're waiting,
just real quick one.
If you're just totally
new to ads--
you've been a developer for a
while, but totally new to the
whole ad world, what's a good
resource just to kind of start
to understand what CPM and
all that stuff means?
VISHAY NIHALANI: We
have extensive
documentation on our website.
I can point to the support
site offline.
AUDIENCE: My question is
more on the video.
So the interstitched video ads
between say a click and
something else that's coming
next, like you showed there.
Is there a way that
kind of works?
Maybe this is more of a
double-click question, but can
you run your own video
ads within that?
Is there a way to control that
inventory, or is that all
sourced inventory
from AdWords--
or what you guys are doing.
VISHAY NIHALANI: So today, all
the inventories source from
AdWords and the YouTube
network.
But we're working on ways to
kind of improve our house ads
functionality to allow you to
serve your own video ads into
applications as well.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question is about,
you mentioned that
you're enabling payments in
local currencies, in quite a
number of countries.
I'm interested in knowing
what countries they
are covering in Africa.
VISHAY NIHALANI: That's
a great question.
We have a huge list.
I don't know it off the top my
head, but I can certainly
point you to the resources.
We are launching local currency
payments just all
over the world.
So we'll definitely
let you know if
your country is supported.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
regarding
the convention tracking.
Let's say when I'm an
advertiser, and I want to
advertise at AdMob,
but I'm also
advertising in other ad networks.
So how well does the new AdMob
work with like third parties
for conversion tracking, and
all these kind of things?
FLO THNG: So if I get the
question correctly, does the
new AdMob support conversion
tracking with other networks?
Is that the question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so when
I want [INAUDIBLE]
AdMob, if I can use third party
tools for conversion
trends so I can integrate, or
if I can use AdMob to also
track the conversions
from other networks.
FLO THNG: That's a
great question.
So for now, we only support
tracking conversion
tracking for AdMob.
And the URL conversion tracking
with third party URL,
we're going to support very
quickly after launch.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question regarding
the filters.
Is it possible to use wild
cards to block certain
keywords, or does it have
to be that exact URL?
Just in case that URL changes
on the other end from the
advertiser.
VISHAY NIHALANI: That's
a great question .
For now, we don't support just
filtering by keywords.
But the URLs are pretty--
we use regular expressions to
kind of match patterns.
So if you put in a regex,
it should work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm pretty interested
in the video ad.
So if you just skip the video
in like the five seconds, so
that's not counted as
a valid ad, right?
So you don't have to
pay for that, or--
VISHAY NIHALANI:
That's correct.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And another question is that the
in cost marketing, so we
should be in the same AdMob
account, right?
So if I want to do the inhouse
ad, so we should in--
FLO THNG: Yes, house ad will
be in the same account.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But sometimes in our firms,
so each person has
his very own account.
How do you solve a problem
like that?
FLO THNG: That's a
good question.
If you stop by the Sandbox
later, I'll actually just
address that with you.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
VISHAY NIHALANI: Cool.
Well, thanks, everyone,
for coming out.
FLO THNG: Wait, I think there's
one more question.
VISHAY NIHALANI: Oh,
AUDIENCE: Is there possible to
insert animated ad banner?
FLO THNG: Yes, animated banner
will be supported.
AUDIENCE: Which format?
For example, can is insert
the Flash ad?
FLO THNG: I can get
back to you.
I don't think-- it's just
a regular format.
I don't think Flash will be.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Do you have any sort of
recommendations on different
ad formats?
So between banners,
interstitials, what performs
the best for different
types of apps?
VISHAY NIHALANI: Yeah, that's
a great question.
I think there are a couple
things to keep in mind.
Typically, you want keep the ad
placements in places where
it makes sense for your users.
So for example, if you're
playing with a game, as you
saw from Toni's video, you want
to keep the ad in a way
that it's not going to interfere
with the experience.
So in his example, he's kind of
got it on the menu screens.
For different apps, different
things work.
We typically find that
interstitials have higher
conversion rates and
clickthrough rates, just
because there's more
of a canvas to
create an engaging ad.
But it really depends
on the applications.
So definitely play around
and experiment.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Hi.
I'm not really avid with AdMob,
but I have a question
about offline application
and your AdMob.
We have a connection for the
people who don't have Wi-Fi or
a connection.
What happens--
can you explain it
a little bit?
VISHAY NIHALANI: Yeah.
So that's a great question.
We've heard this feature request
a number of times.
We have nothing to announce just
yet, but we're certainly
kind of thinking about
this use case.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious about whether this
system is compatible with
these new regulations that are
coming into effect in July,
related to advertising to
children under the age of 13.
Or whether you have, in fact,
terms of service that would
say you can't use this
system with children
under the age of 13.
C-O-P-P-A, COPPA regulation.
VISHAY NIHALANI: That's
a great question.
I'll have to follow up with
you offline on that one.
In general, we always keep the
user experience at the
forefront of what we do.
We want to make sure that we're
compliant with all of
the sort of legal regulations.
And just kind of keeping
users in mind as we
develop these ads.
Cool.
Well, thanks a lot
for coming out.
Definitely come and visit
us at the I/O booth
we have just outside.
And we're happy to answer any
more questions you might have.
Thanks.